ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi facciamo
una delle cose che diverte più in
assoluto e da tantissimo tempo che non
era così gasato nel provare qualcosa
perché oggi proveremo il set da fon
questa meraviglia del creato è uno dei
miei ricordi legati all'infanzia con
questa qui ci mangiavano quando erano
piccoli i miei fratelli tutti ricordi
certo tutto il ricorderemo magici mamma
e osteno guerra guerra
oggi però non proveremo una ricetta
nemmeno 2 e proveremo 3 far in una
fonduta di formaggio faremo una carne
alla buchi nonna e soprattutto faremo
una fonduta di cioccolato
fondamentalmente come funziona da tante
e non più da dietro luogo serve per
uccidere questa quella parte che
sostiene tutto quanto nella quale
inserisce sia il fornelletto dal quale
appunto uscirà il fuoco e sopra ci va la
pentola all'interno della quale
metteremo degli ingredienti diversi
infine queste specie di sperun 5 oltre
che per uccidere gli altri servono pure
per cucinare le varie cose quindi bando
alle ciance partiamo subito con il
primissimo esperimento la fonduta di
formaggio per la ricetta sto seguendo il
blog di giallo zafferano e soprattutto
sto seguendo lo stile di fonduta
francese voi direte qual è la differenza
quella italiana ci mette dentro il latte
se non sbaglio quella francese ci mette
dentro il vino e noi ci metteremo il
vino pare che questo piatto io non l'ho
mai mai mai provato in vita mia ho
sempre avuto così tanti problemi col
formaggio che l'idea demaniale
il film avrebbe fatto schifo col tempo
un po migliorato i gusti quindi speriamo
in qualche modo sta roba se maneggiabile
che non diventi in er brema gip dei
piedi in primo formaggio asiago
stagionato 100 grammi
tutto questo abbiamo perdonato gianmarco
ed è qui con noi gianmarco è come i
ragazzi non mi tocca ne hai capito che c
è ragione gian marco cerreto la
scaramanzia tra pareva troppo personale
anzi dovessi ringraziare perché se siamo
fortunati non una cagata pure logiche
tagliamolo a obiettivi e infiliamo le
passioni il groviera
grazie mille e cento grammi sempre nel
territorio di questo non sembra proprio
apprendibili quanti ti supplico di
supplenza politico anche a casa famiglia
dove spiega cenare a cheap present
dicono non ce la faccio più in anno ma
mi fece dire un attimo presenti
veramente se avete qualche effetto di
quelli degli effetti che poi a parigi
fise l'estate ma se è vero esempio i
ristoranti infestati di web di
quell'odore tesa quanto entra vive il
ristorante senti lip dub e poi dice è
passato il rio
ragazzi io ho visto persone che lo
facevano chiappari gigi de paris le
misure con le questo qui è una fontina
tutto dentro sempre raga ma è una
caxxata da fare se veramente così
ricorda che il fattore lavoro io povero
e mentale ma emmental questo qui è
mentale penso fosse nemmeno ma come
certa che lo fonte si fa ci va da
inzuppare del pane adesso troviamo
guarda che bello è tutto uguale
ciao a tutti i formaggi diversi allora
100 millilitri di vino invece che la
creazione la francese e quindi bisogna
testare le tratte stiamo 100 millilitri
prima serve per le salse vigor niente
grandina aggiungiamo la 1 spicchio
d'aglio infilano dentro sempre ea questo
punto la parte divertente ma che me la
più pericolosa bisogna starci attenti il
fornelletto qua sotto nella bio avete un
link per comprarne una seconda è
fighissima io mi sa che fatti a
sostituirlo con questa allora ok anche
di questi l sul link e descrizione sono
semplicemente delle specie di
omogeneizzati e altamente tossici e
infiammabili è un gelati non è però che
la piazza di gelatina in cui un cd
mi raccomando ragazzi assicuratevi di
chiuderlo per bene caverete questo
cosino qui per regolare la fiamma questo
per spegnerla accendiamo occhio o meno
ecco aspetta no no no questi di vetro
marco cioè macro jamal giorno
laboratorio in fiamme non c'è rischio
che un incendio è peggio di se si fosse
m
aspettiamo che si sciolga tutto mi
raccomando ragazzi fiamma al minimo per
evitare di farlo bruciare attaccare
sotto la cosa [ __ ] e che slow food
questo doppio aggiunto molto del
fornetto ma con calma ma a tutto al
centro del piano questo che si scioglie
le facciano po di pezza a sentire puzza
di bruciato hammami a regaleranno devi
abbassare pianificando non lo brucia
cooper che veramente è possibile che ci
viene mai dice gianmarco l'altro è
un'auto gianmarco io non possa essere il
capro espiatorio di questi fallimenti
non è questo guardate che non è questo
come però secondo me qui viene bruciato
per informarci lo ammetti armato di
chiedo scusa per aver pubblicato di the
pirate vienna il colpevole sempre stato
guglielmo per un opportunità si è
sbarazzato di me spostando l'attenzione
sì sì sì è un furbo generoso che abbiamo
smascherato questo non mi pare l'odore
che c'era nei ristoranti di bari dove
dovreste abbassare l'arma lo sanno tutti
va il formaggio fuso nel pentolino di
soul eater fiamma al minimo e coperchio
così che si esce a shoreditch eletto
grazie gianmarco tu si che si è
essenziale in questo format mi
raccomando ragazzi fiamma al minimo per
evitare di farlo bruciare attaccare
sotto
tante volte ma molto prima aveva passato
di tantissimo le fiamme forse semi
ripresa sembra buono è sì siamo così
all'inizio con le altre due come ti amo
come del formaggio è la cosa più
difficile è far mangiare la superficie è
vero abbiamo improvvisato un coperchio
tutto questo o rame si sta scendendo
velocemente questa yeah yeah
ovvio ma ci siamo quasi
si va all assaggio io detentive crostone
fonduta filante l'insieme di formaggi e
interessantissimo il leggero anno se vi
piace tenetelo altrimenti sapete che si
sente a me fa impazzire sappiatelo
quindi faccio la terrei tutta la vita
non ho avuto 10 ti stai esponendo
volevano anche voi indirizza ai
a dargli un voto per santissimo ragazzi
10 dai non ci credo dovrei diversi
giorni dopo
io non sono proprio un amante folle del
formaggio è però proviamo buonissimo
questo mix di sapori formaggio xi pop
io non ho mai assaggiato questo genere
di cose ma sempre sognato di farlo
chiaramente deve essere bello carico che
sta combinando un ora ho capito i vostri
voti
ho capito perché consolidare 10 devo
capire meglio però pastelli oppure fammi
capire il cambio fuori io pure
meglio se ne andiamo con il secondo
esperimento la carne alla mourinho non
avremmo bisogno di un filetto che qua
vedete intero cisco che sia per dire
così si atteggia la carne in acqua e
vento forza allora non è una tosta
cagata versi siamo possiamo quanti giu
possiamo aprire di nuovo il fornelletto
e riempire questa volta con un po di
olio in realtà sarebbe da riempire però
facciamo un pochino di economia voglio
dire solo per le 4 potenza massima
lasciamo andare metto a preparare la
carnia che ricordiamo che gli oli
esausti vanno sempre portati nei punti
di raccolta e non scaricati in eccesso
in realta sarebbe un po a togliere il
grasso o semi capire perso il grosso
mezzo che gode invece quindi non lo
toglieremo sappiate la carne super palma
noi a coltello
ok eccezionale negli occhi si il morso
deve essere interessante da calcio è una
cosa pazzesca assolutamente avesse cui
vengono anche con una delle terrin e con
delle piccole ciotoline andiamo a fare
al volessimo kresal se maionese senape
di digione marchi
comunque sto pensando che le false fanno
gli stessi rumori che poi tu quando vai
al cesso dopo esser telemann tale che
questa ripudio perché non volevo
gianmarco
questa crociera maionese e aggiungo un
pochino di paprika dolce così vedevo un
pochino più di senape pepe nero sarebbe
meglio se la mente del bianco però ci
sta da dio ma barbecue nasce così
rischio tac
abbiamo delle salsine con le quali
gustare la nostra carne guglielmo qui
non puoi sbagliare vietato usare per una
vera con la figuraccia secondo me è qui
invece non puoi portare dispiegarsi in
ostaggio sei canzoni che ti amo andato
padre vasto forcone ricaccia la presa
sarebbe cascato
passiamo infiamma trarne e lasciamolo
cucinare allora prendi lo diventa eco
luca questa prendo a parte che è
buonissimo ma dovete levarmi subito
perché si stanno traducendo 10 10 detto
anche la salsetta si presenti poi il
bozzolo e certosino è più buona la
fonduta mamma mia
io la preferisco la conduce a questa
comunque 9 o soldato no però devo dare
un voto ai ragazzi anche io voto 9
forse con un pizzico di sale allora ne
avanzato uno già che sono qui cambia
salto la seconda per serve un lavoro
esperimento numero 3 era del momento del
dolce facciamo una fonduta di cioccolato
non posso dire che sono estremamente
emozionato io no tu non senti modo per
venire i due esperimenti questo è quello
che mi e cerca almeno di ciano dormire
da esse romperci col prendiamo 200 g di
cioccolato fondente e lo tagliamo super
finemente quant'è che ci fai un ajami
secondo la ricetta 150 ha dimenticato di
ordinare la panna la panna serve per
verificarlo e fare quell effetto
profondità anche perché tutto questo
facciamo con le favole che lei in studio
una cosa che mi piace arrivare un po ma
una parolina e ne vedo una piccolissima
di terreno 150 millilitri anni diventati
accende il fuoco con la panna l'intero
album butta a terra tutta a terra subito
capire che poteva iscrivere gentilmente
un insulto queste due teste 150 conca un
miracolo che non si sia rotto questo
caso di pietro ragazzi mi regolo che non
abbia ucciso che non è buttato per terra
sono biologica e se fragole perché sono
tutte diverse tutte brutte sono
buonissimi e accendono il fuoco
nel frattempo che è inscritta dare il
cioccolato come cartello berica posso
dirti che dà una soddisfazione
pazzesca lo sventato proprio per
facilitare processo di scioglimento
se potessi tornare indietro informato
l'avrete andato molto più piccolino
tutto questo shock un fornelletto che
continua ad andare con una sola carica
lo stiamo della attivo da un pochino
succedesse prendo questo è qui e le
preparo al volo secondo me il primo è
proprio da primo appuntamento prima cina
a casa primo appuntamento il primo
appuntamento con avviata deformati primo
appuntamento poi fare le star le fragole
ok si è ritratto guarda anche più veloce
del previsto ha messo tre secondi
quest'estate ha messo di più il
formaggio e dell'olio e un di più il
formaggio dovevamo fare un pochino più
sminuzzato con cui uno può fare in una
serata tutti e tre primo secondo e dolce
kamber bruciate
se posso dire che in una contenuta dopo
23 anni di relazione secondo me fonduta
di formaggio cioccolato e carne al
booking come le teste all'interno della
nostra ricaccia primo appuntamento ma
anche cene con gli amici e voi oppure la
condivido il margine per diretti lazio a
puntare per proprio appuntamento fragole
in banale troppo banale non aggancia
faccia un atto al primo appuntamento
degli essere banale
le cose ai canali dedicheranno non fai
più quale lo sai che faceva il 3
appuntamento e non lo puoi prendere quel
che istituito banale facciamo con
l'assaggio di morti il san vito un
pizzino di center freccia 4 salato
proprio primato cerco il sabato perché
se no ma parla cagata fratelli perfetta
fragole sarà certo
qua devo essere sincera mi aspettavo
molto maggio perché non sono un fan
destra ma io vorrei mettere un pochino
di sale sopra cambia tutto più buono
sarà il cioccolato per me una roba bomba
però ha preferito sempre il salato 8 ho
avuto l'idea sale beh intingo
leggermente la fragola anche questa
manovra di sale un pizzico nocciole per
l'hiv interessante bona ma con riserve
preventivo il salato set e proverò
l'assaggio alla guglielmo ok
ecco la clip più un buon esperimento non
mi piace troppo mischiare un frutto
fresco come la fragola con il cioccolato
un abbinamento che non mi fa impazzire
però al gusto è positivo non mi
abbuffare di questa roba
io fossi io prendo un bel fragolone a me
piacciono molto le fragole
sbagliato neanche cioccolato è vivo e
sta facendo la pulizia della pelle per
cento ragazzi scusate ma ce la farebbe
lissa erotico viene un bacino erotico
nocciole e via con l'assaggio
mi aspettavo molto molto meglio davvero
in che senso cioè la fragola così al
cioccolato e da 10 nel nocciolo 10 ma
questa unione non mi fa impazzire anche
a me certe primo posto fonduta di
formaggio con 38 punti secondo posto
carni alla bourguignonne con 37 punti e
infine dopo un conteggio sommario
abbiamo condotta di cioccolato con 28
ponte questa classifica naturalmente è
vero in parte perché il mio voto
potrebbe ribaltare il risultato finale
ma lo ribalta assolutamente non conferma
soltanto come sempre fa decise per qua
sotto secondo voi chi vince a livello
fisico cioccolato formaggio carne cos'è
che vorreste provare se lo trovate
fateci state le cose preferite ancora
una volta ragazzi qui sotto vi lasciamo
il link per acquistare col singolo di
questi se ne avete voglia metteteci un
bel pollice in su per il gol
scrivete a questo canale ci vediamo
martedì con una puntata del blog ciao
veramente piaceva e buona sì questa è
un'ottima sa in base anche per farla
garage
[Risate]